hey everybody how's it going my name's
mayuko and welcome back to my channel
where we talk about
tech career and life so it is back to
school time
i know that like it looks really
different from every back to school
season prior
but it's happening everyone's going back
to school and getting their education
so today we're going to talk about my
back-to-school essentials
but mayuko you haven't been in school
for a long time
yes i am well aware of that but also i
know that half of y'all who watch my
videos are in school
and also you don't have to be like 18 to
22 in order to go back to school you can
go to school at any time in your life so
yeah there's a lot of things going on in
this video but really i wanted to talk
about what kind of
environment can you create for yourself
at home since a lot of people aren't
physically going back to school because
of corona
so you can still get into kind of that
academic studying vibe
so in this video i'm going to talk about
a combination of like
physical things that you can use to
study that i really enjoy using even in
my day-to-day life
as well as what things you can do at
home that are free to you
that can create that kind of learning
environment and i also just wanted to
talk about some of the physical stuff
because i
love stationery and i love geeking out
about it too
so this is a chance for me to do so in
the context of box to school so
here we go so the first back to school
essential is going to be
writing tools my writing tools largely
fall into kind of two categories
one for like actually writing and taking
notes and then the other to kind of help
embellish and make things fun
and color-coded and organized so for the
first half of like the writing utensils
there's two things that i use
one of which are muji pens i love using
the black ones in .38
they just glide super well the ink
doesn't run out that quickly
they're very reliable the shape and
style of them are also really pretty and
kind of look
great with any notebook even just for
that alone i am so glad that muji came
to the us
and then the second writing tool that i
have is actually a fountain pen
i picked this up because a notebook that
i have is made for fountain pens so i
figured why not try it out
so i have the koco fountain pen and it
is
gorgeous i don't exactly remember what
it's called or anything but all of the
products and stuff will be linked in the
description box down below so you can
check that out
i really like this fountain pen it
writes super well glides really nicely
it gives me a variation of different
thickness and thinness depending on how
i write
and the blue ink color that i have is
also really pretty and easy on the eyes
it also just feels cool to just like
have a fountain pen like it gets me
hyped about writing because i feel like
having a fountain pen feels like i'm
like
legit writing even if i'm just writing
notes and scribbles and stuff
so those are my two mains when it comes
to actually writing things down
and then in the kind of fun help
organize and colorful category i've got
a couple things
first are these stabilo pens holy cow
i love them i have so many colors in
them they're really like
relatively inexpensive for how many that
you get and i love the felt tipped
pen of it it's really thin tipped it's
really easy to write they don't dry out
and all the different colors are really
fun to play with the second are these
mid liner pens that i picked up in japan
i love them i like that there is a thin
tip and a thick tip so i can kind of use
it as like a highlighter even
and play around with different shapes
the colors i really really like of this
one
and it kind of just makes it fun so that
i can make certain words into headlines
and kind of scribble around and make
things look nice
really i think a lot of my writing
pencils just make writing and taking
notes
fun uh and it's fun to like be excited
about writing things down with like your
new shiny pens
and then also in this fun category i've
got like a small collection of washi
tape
i've got a couple from muji which are
really sleek and minimalist but also a
little bit japanese
and then i've also got these snoopy
stickers because they love snoopy
and i will take every chance that i get
to embellish my notes
in snoopy so those are the things i used
to write things down and take notes
next i wanted to talk about notebooks so
i typically tend to use two kinds of
notebooks when i'm studying anything
one is kind of like my main i drop
everything in there
except for like class and book notes and
so these are things like bullet journal
spreads if i decide to do one one week
sometimes journal entries sometimes just
like random notes and to-do lists and
drawings and thoughts and stuff that i
just want to dump so i've got the seven
seas crossfield notebook and this is the
japan version that i bought
apparently the squares in them are
perfect for like
japanese writing or something like that
uh
but i found this in japan and i am in
love with it this is actually like the
first notebook that i've like filled
more than halfway
and you know that like sound that you
get when you like fill
in enough notebook pages like this sound
just that like touch and the sound the
feel of a
like full notebook is something that i
now realize i've been missing out on
because i had such a hard time filling
notebooks like these
but yeah i got it in this really pretty
blue color i put stickers on it
it's really easy to write the pages are
like pretty thin
uh and so this this is actually the
notebook that i bought my
fountain pen for it's a little bit soft
like the pages are a little bit soft for
a muji pen
because it'll kind of like bleed over to
the other side but it's great for
stabilo pens it's great for fountain
pens
and i just love using this thing so this
is like my everyday
notebook the notebooks that i use to
take actual class notes are
campus notebooks i think these are like
really japanese notebooks to have
but i really really like them i've been
using them since like high school
because i just bought a bunch in bulk
and they are really really great for
class notes so the thing that i like
most about them is that they're really
thin
and small in the days in which we're
going outside and going to class
physically
and you're hauling a backpack full of
notebooks it was nice to have something
super lightweight and small so that
you're not just lugging around extra
weight
i also really like the size of these
notebooks and the lines of them
too feel like they were like perfectly
sized for my kind of handwriting
and usually i would go through like one
or two of these in a
semester or for a class and then i would
just have like a neat
group of notebooks for any given class i
don't actually know if they sell these
ones specifically but i know this brand
is still around and if you look on like
asian stationery websites or maybe even
amazon you can definitely still find
these
what i also used to do too is just go to
like my local daiso and just get like a
bunch of japanese notebooks
because they tend to be like a smaller
footprint even if they have a spiral
they're much smaller spirals
and so they were just a little bit
easier to like work with
and haul around so these are kind of
like my writing notes essentials
i use a lot of these in college actually
back in the day
and i still use them whenever i'm
writing things down or i'm learning a
new topic
my next back to school essential which
this is like an essential for like all
of life
is a phone case and i have a couple of
cases from casetify that i really want
to show you today which is like now
like a staple of mine in my everyday
life
oh and this video is also sponsored by
case defy so thanks for sponsoring i've
always had a case on my phone because i
accidentally throw it or drop it or
something
and so i've been loving these
case-to-phy cases case-fly cases are
known for how good they are
at protecting your phone i in fact did a
drop test and while it was pretty scary
to do so
my phone survived just fine and the
front didn't crack at all
i also feel like getting a new case
sometimes feels like you're getting a
new phone but for way cheaper
because it breathes new life into your
phone they have a ton of prints to
choose from
and you can also customize your own case
where you can choose your own color
and font so if you want to match phone
cases with me
go to casify.com myugo
and get 20 off today the link is also in
the description box down below
in caseify thanks so much for sponsoring
the next one i feel like
is the back to school essential for me
because i don't go anywhere without them
even when i'm home and that's like my
water bottle
right now i'm just using like a contigo
one that i picked up at target
it holds like i don't know almost like a
liter of water
and it's a straw i bought this one
because i wanted something that i could
use to drink water like while i'm
driving like it fits in a cup holder
it's a straw top so i don't have to like
spill water all over my face
now that we're not really like going to
places this is just what i have
but again like when you're going to
class and you're like hauling a lot of
stuff
i used to use a hydroflask water bottle
but they're really really heavy
and so having something a little bit
more lightweight and the only weight
that you're carrying is the water was
something that's really important and
really helped me to like
avoid back injury basically i always
have this right next to me on my desk
even now
i feel like while you're working or
studying it's a really good opportunity
to hydrate
and also it's just important to hydrate
if you're sitting for long periods of
time
and so just make sure you hydrate folks
with a really good water bottle
so those are all the physical things
that i use on a day-to-day basis now
and also that i used in college and
while i was in school
that really helped me with my learning
and now i want to talk about
things that you can do to your space
that can help with that too and the
first of which
is music i'm someone who likes to listen
to music while studying
it's good white noise for me and if it's
the right kind of music i feel like it
gets my brain juices flowing
and it makes me think better and it gets
me into that kind of like i'm gonna do
work and
steady mood and this should come as no
surprise but it's chill hop everybody
lo-fi hip-hop all day every day for me
when i was in college that genre didn't
really like exist
and so i listened to a lot of nujabes
and uyama hiroto
who create like really chill nice beats
to study to
but in 2020 chillhop lo-fi hip-hop stuff
is everywhere which is great
and so there's a couple of playlists
that i love listening to on spotify
as well as like a soundcloud playlist
that i made for myself that i listen to
when i'm studying
the second thing that you can do to your
space to help you study
is to associate studying with a smell
there's a lot of science about how
smell and your olfactory senses are
really
really strong at associating certain
memories in certain moods and
environments and so
i use that as a way to also help me
create
a nice environment so usually when i'm
sitting or working i either have a
candle on
or i spray some perfume on myself or
maybe it's just the smell of coffee
right now i'm burning this one which is
meraki white tea and ginger
i picked this up in norway during my
honeymoon in scandinavia last year and
it
just smells so good it's a very clean
scent
and i like this one i also have been
using a
perfume sample that i got from asoc
which is also very like
woody but also floral and the last thing
that i do to help with creating a space
is to find a quiet space to work in now
i know this one's tricky because i know
a lot of y'all are moving back in with
your parents or you have roommates or
something
but i do think that having a focus quiet
study space which you know in
traditional terms might be going to like
a library or a lab
is really important to have a place to
think so i think there's two ways to go
about this
one is to drown out everybody else with
something like noise cancelling
headphones which i sometimes use
or you can have a conversation with the
people you live with and negotiate kind
of like
a quiet study time so that you can set
boundaries for yourself
and for them so that you can still get
this quiet study time that you need like
on a schedule or something
and the last thing that i want to talk
about which is neither like a physical
thing or a space
is a system that you can set up for
yourself so when you're going to school
i think one of the best things about
going to
school physically is that you're seeing
other people
you're working with them you are
studying with them you're interacting
with your teacher
but because of covet times we're not
really doing that because we want to be
safe and not
give corona to everybody but i think
there is a lot of value in seeing people
face to face
and having that be a motivator for you
to get your work done
so a system that i think could really
help you with this is to find a way for
you
and your friends to hold each other
accountable i show this in the recent
vlog
but i have a stand-up with my friends
like every day
monday through friday where we just talk
about what we did yesterday and what
we're gonna do today
and that alone has been really helpful
and one getting me out of bed and two
talking to other people about what i'm
gonna do but it really is just about
checking in with each other and
supporting each other especially through
this like
weird time in history in which y'all are
going back to school
so that's it for this video thanks so
much for watching make sure to click
subscribe if you want to see more videos
like this
and leave a comment down below and tell
me what essentials that you have
for this upcoming school year i will see
you in the next one and hope you have a
great day wherever you are
bye